this girl looks like it she's so lucky
he gets older right
she should wake up every morning
thanking her [ __ ] lucky stars I want
to clip he chose her she should wake up
every morning pray too wait a minute
had to run it back cause we back at it
again yeah we gon keep it moving like
it's never gonna end when it was Brendan
when it was Brighton but it was just
talking to friends we got the kid
calling on the left with the fighter on
the right had to do it right cause we
coming at you locked back with the team
had to keep it all G my CTV yes
back at it again it's the fighter in the
kid
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
guys welcome let's go welcome to fighter
and the kid fighter and the killed
fight around the kid how about that
poster I text you uh old school old
school fighter in the kitchen I love it
the poster I think was what remember did
that tour we did like Chicago yes uh
well it's Milwaukee yeah like it was we
did that tour I have those dope posters
made I remember you said that was Justin
edbook this dude was uh cleaning my
office look at this thing
wasn't hung up
he didn't respond
we just do those old school tours I know
what tattoo I'm getting
um
yeah now I'm
I'm a little bit cocky today
I can deadlift 300 pounds
okay
one with good form once
probably more than that but we don't
want to push it we don't want to push it
this is how you get hurt so I'll do it
one time I'll do it one time and then
work up to it that's all but you know
when you're a certain age you don't want
to be getting a little crazy Brian
didn't post it yet all right yeah you'd
only go two nuts on it yeah
you know yeah deadlift like when I was
doing the when I had crazy in the
deadlift and I was just doing the uh
did that summer I still that's the
number one work that I do I remember
your back like I did 600 pounds in my
back I could feel it
I was like I remember thinking after I
had done it was cool I got it I was like
what are you doing yeah who gives a [ __ ]
oh much how's this help you in life yeah
I guess if you know like well also I'm
sorry but no matter who you are at when
you start pushing 40 and you're doing
that kind of weight you got to be
careful something something well you
just gotta warm up like yeah you gotta
warm up how do you warm up but but I do
enjoy there's something about like I
lifted heavy I farmer carried 130 pounds
in each hand a lot not far like maybe
you know I don't know how many years 10
yards okay I mean that part but but the
point is that it's heavy for me right
yeah like or maybe 20 yards yeah and
then push the sled with Brian Shaw on
all after him yeah so real quick the
listeners know you're assuming they all
know you're in Denver
I went to his gym I went to his house
worked out with him ate food with him
and in Denver Colorado Denver um we're
near there near Colorado Springs oh wow
did you find Colorado Springs Denver but
it was only uh how far no it's only like
25 minutes from the airport
that's Denver but we can tell it's City
that's Denver because the airports
40 minutes from here yeah because
Obama's bunkers under there you know
that I don't know oh that's yeah he's
bunkers I did not know this is these are
facts though if there's a nuclear war
like they're launching a nuclear war
they have a place in Denver and in uh
Iowa oh God watch this this is so funny
that's him that's Brian Shaw measuring
his arm to my leg
and I'm not gonna say how that went I'm
not gonna say how that went but wow that
would be Brian Shaw he's so big
um dude I'm telling you about he's
what's that what size shoe is that well
I'm glad I'm glad you asked let me guess
let me guess shoe size how tall is he be
uh he's six eight he's 400 how many
pounds he's brown or too much let's say
440 pounds 400 too much right uh 40 is
410 450. probably 450 because it'd be
nice uh I'll say is a size 16 17. so why
I will say this why so I will say this
we I wanted to make them a pair of toe
holds I wanted to bring a pair of
flip-flops
but AJ said well have him measure his
foot
he measured his foot and AJ said we
don't have a die that big we don't have
a because when you make shoes you have
to have a uh like a die you know like a
like a little task yeah did you cut the
leather because we have to have that
made because that's the biggest foot
I've ever seen but why wouldn't you just
do two of your biggest and then cut in
you can't that's not how it works okay
because where your foot is and where the
arch is it's all specific right so his
foot is over 14 inches long well no what
size is that though so that that would
be somewhere around in 18 19 20.
disaster disaster oh dressing up hey not
for you he he has to make have his jeans
made for him and thank God they have
some stretchiness he shops wherever
gorilla shop at there's nothing he said
it's the biggest pain in the ass the
other thing is there are some planes the
man cannot fit in oh that's easy when
he's got a pee in uh airplane you have
to keep the door open yeah you do she's
a he's a Silverback Gorilla yeah like
whatever issues silver or black girls
have he has the same problem yeah if you
want to put jeans on Silverback go ahead
that's right you'll be cutting some
clothes yeah you're talking about you're
talking about a man who who is who is
mostly bone and muscle and all of that
equals anywhere between 4 15 and 465
depending more muscle than bone and then
just so you guys so again we're assuming
it's like we're talking about four times
the strongest man in the world from
college Colorado's finest don't get
twists because whatever water he's
drinking add a little bit add a little
bit proud American by the way proud
American I would hope so yeah I assume
well that's that's his wife she was a
crossfitter and that's Brian no that's a
real picture right there that's not
that's not Photoshop that's the
difference in size and his wife is in
shape his wife's tall too though oh yeah
she's not tall but she's yeah if he's
six eight yes sir if he's six hey she's
minimum five eleven uh no not that tall
she's about she's about five
I don't know all the other kids yeah by
the way that his kid was four years old
beautiful little kids it was four I go
is that the six-year-old she goes that's
the four-year-old so she's like that's
four years and practice hurt your
feelings she's stronger than that now
there you go there's Brian that like
looking at me he's so proportioned
though like I said to him I go your face
fits your body oh yeah and thank God he
grew the goatee right yeah and look at
how wide he is Sir look at this body
there he looks like Mr Incredible like
remember was out of shape and trying to
get the thing yes he does but he was
still like yeah he's Mr Incredible he's
also here's what you would love about
him and what I love he's [ __ ] uh just
a silly goose he's a fun silly goose
he's just one of those guys just a great
guy well Jesus Christ you guys are
jacked where did he uh Eddie Hall
hey uh chin where did he grow I know
he's Colorado Springs Guy where do you
go to high school in college I think
Colorado
he's not a University of Colorado okay I
would know that yeah early life
you went to Fort Lupton High School
excelled in basketball they intended
Junior College in La Junta Colorado
um yeah
uh just anything
for as far as College yeah or yes High
School College yeah I kept talking about
people who I knew who were strong and he
would go huh uh-huh yeah why am I
talking about this to you yeah you you
you can you can squat 700 pounds for
reps
because he won he was the main guy
forever so world's strongest in 2011
2013.
um recently he finished four he also
tied for first he finished second tied
for first in that one well now that
Arnold strongman's kind of almost bigger
like Arnold strongman's a big event yeah
yeah it is
yeah it's splintered off right so when
pushanowski was five-time champ oh I
used to love him as a kid he a lot of
the strongest guys went to another
division though
so it's a little bit skewed
um
yeah I feel like strong men fell off a
little bit I mean that Eddie Hall he's a
personality who's gonna ask you as big
but his personality right so yeah you
know he's doing MMA now I'm aware
um but I feel like strong wind back in
the day with like pujanowski and some of
those other guys that Maximus or
whatever it was so big in the also the
Mr Olympia because they had those
personalities I feel like the the Mr
Olympia and the strong ones kind of
like they're not very good at social
media so it's not like in the Limelight
anymore it's kind of like this back to
this underground thing yeah name a big
bodybuilder yeah that's that's true they
they that
is something I think that's not lost on
well uh than the Thor from uh from Game
of Thrones was a strong man yes he was a
world champion he was World Champ at one
point yeah that's sovekis Civic he's got
he was the man yeah yeah he's the police
first team all fit yes now ball I
believe Brian is the biggest strong man
to ever walk the earth I think Thor's
bigger so Thor and here are about the
same no Four's taller I think Thor's
almost seven foot well he said they were
about the same height
um and they both are uh you can click on
them they're both about the same height
yeah and now but here's the difference
six eight yeah but here's the difference
Brian is a hundred pounds heavier that's
right that's insane it's insane I've
never seen I'm telling you ever seen
pictures of Thor in high school
uh he looked like you at seven foot tall
well so he was his arms were getting
this big yeah well so Brian Shaw the
last time he was 200 pounds was when he
was 11. and he used to work on his look
at that yeah wow
go to early picture of Brian Shaw but
but but Brian Brian was a basketball
player and he he played um he grew up
working on his uncle's Farm sir so when
he was 11 12 years old he was bailing 60
pound bales of hay so he was always just
strong as [ __ ] hey B let's take a little
break from talking about your mom yeah
let's take a little break because this
episode is brought to you by Better
Health better help yeah well sometimes
you need to take a break from everything
and take care of your brain life is your
state of mind dude life doesn't come
with a user's manual so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck well you want to talk to somebody
who's a professional who can help you
who can listen right what about somebody
that's helped over three million people
worldwide licensed therapist we're
talking about Better Health yeah 100
online B 100 online you can you can be
paired up with uh an affordable
therapist within 48 hours and you can
speak to somebody over the phone or you
can zoom whatever it might be
um they're trained to help you figure
out the causes of challenging emotions
you can learn how to be productively
cope with things and uh it basically is
something that people forget about yeah
it's important you need to take care
it's like in mental hygiene yeah well as
the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professional license and
vetted therapists is available 100
online plus like Brian said it's
affordable all right just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist things are clicking you can
easily switch a new therapist anytime no
big deal no waiting easy no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more save ten percent
off your first month betterhelp.com
fighter that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash fighter now listen
dude yeah sometimes you don't get enough
fruits and vegetables that's impossible
sometimes you don't get enough vitamins
sometimes you need something that you
can absorb you know uh athletic greens
is that's what we use it is my multivite
I know some of the most productive
people on the planet including Mr Joe
Rogan who takes this pretty much every
day it's about ag-1 by athletic the
category leading superfood product it
has everything in it no pills I just put
a little their pouch into eight ounces
of water 75 vitamins 75 vitamins
minerals Whole Food Source ingredients
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic a
greens superfood blend I mean you got it
all the healthier and delicious
digestion it's fantastic join the
movement of athletes life people moms
dads rookies first timers podcasters
comedians we all take it ag1 and to make
it easy
I'll do it I feel like greens is going
to give you guys an immune supporting
free one-year supply of vitamin D and
five free travel packs with your first
first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today all you
gotta do is go to athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give aj1 a try now let's get back to
the program just thick look that's back
in the day Young Brian Charles he's
massive yes yes just always crazy strong
isn't it weird like Kim world champion
Thor world champion I'll have basketball
backgrounds yes well Tall the thing
about Brian is that he's super
competitive in everything he does if you
challenge him to something he's oh he
did play football yeah because they they
said to him they said you
um you're too tall to be a strong man
that's what they said and he goes what
and he goes it's impossible for you to
be the strongest man in the world and he
goes well you can't say that to me he's
that kind of guy
but I'm telling you dude forget all that
expensive humor fun guy you would love
him he's one of us yeah he's a silly
goose who just loves people no I've
always rooted for him because the
Colorado boy yeah we're like when he was
winning like Kelly he's just a [ __ ]
great guy I I had so much fun with him
now did you witness his meal plan I
didn't witness his meal plan oh really
you only had one meal he made me lunch
what was the lunch it was a demure lunch
it was just it was about uh two and a
half pounds of grass-fed beef like a
steak or a ground uh ground up lean
grass-fed steak white rice white rice
and and smashed sweet potatoes yep there
you go and some sea salt and not much
seasoning nope delicious oh was it nice
it was nice well they get good with it
because they gotta eat like that
[ __ ] all the time and I hadn't eaten
and I was working on no sleep so I got
there and I did a whole workout I'll eat
that right now and then daddy ate that
whole thing oh yeah right now oh man it
makes you feel like oh he brings you all
his ass right now makes you feel good
yeah dude that stuff and they're so good
at it because that's all they eat that
bland [ __ ]
at this place called Mercantile in in uh
Colorado and Union Station that's when's
Last Time went to Union Station amazing
yeah you haven't been there a while no
that's our spot that's our coffee shops
there's a snooze in there thank you yeah
and by the way in the hotel across the
street state of the Crawford right there
right there that's where you want to
stay yeah yep and and stayed there shout
out to the Crawford great Hotel
Mercantile unbelievable food like Jelena
you we you I gotta we gotta go what did
big man eat so the big man we got there
and we ordered everything on the menu
basically because I lost a bet I lost a
bet what's the bet a lifting competition
whose weather is my leg or his arm was
bigger let's see I'm just gonna leave it
at that it's an easy bet okay yeah I
mean dude either way I don't want to
give too much away but the point is well
they know we ate we ate some food there
oh the BET was dinner and he had venison
no they had much this be yeah did he now
how many did he bring the kiddos and the
wife he did not although they were
invited it was the big band The World
Champ you and my staff and my crew
that's not terrible not bad and I and
and I he goes I won't eat pasta but he
goes you got any potatoes
so he's all about power food then desert
and he goes uh do you have cheesecake oh
I bet he did and they didn't have
cheesecake and he goes I'm good then I
want why he goes cheesecake that's a
power meal he he's it's all about the
calories it's all about power it's all
about whatever he believes is best for
his and he thinks cheesecakes power
that would be the only dessert he would
probably allow himself to have he's very
strict it's all calorie dense Maybe
yeah and he said the hardest thing is is
eating like the amount they have to eat
that's what's tough you ever see Bradley
Martin asked him what the grossest thing
he ever ate was he goes well I took a
bunch of tuna
and put it in a blender with some orange
juice and just drank it down
I was so Savage
exactly what I want to hear out of
Rancho that's that's like anybody Savage
dude
tuna yeah the in the can yeah in oranges
just for a little glucose that sugar and
then the lean protein from tuna correct
probably ran out of protein powder was
like I got it yep have you have you ever
had like put on weight like that where
you're eating all the time like I've not
I've had to you've had to it's miserable
it's miserable right when you're not
hungry and you can eat a lot but you
don't want to eat no I really don't eat
that much yeah you actually don't
especially now like well you're you're
actually you're body sensitive you're
actually pretty sensitive right so like
you don't feel well we don't sleep you
know you're not the guy who could just
no I'm not gonna let you just Powers
through it like having to eat when
you're not hungry
and like in every two hours enjoy that
[ __ ] like yeah in football they always
wanted to put on weight and like in the
Summers I'm like trying to grill steaks
you know how much money I have this
[ __ ] at the Times Jemima's white rice
right not the white rice they changed
that name I think but the the white rice
and you're just down in that it's
calories and then you just feel sluggish
it's not natural no and then back then
we'd have like the pills for digestive
enzymes like break it down right when
you don't look good yeah when you see a
lot of these guys who are like forget
strongman just guys who are fitness
models like they look a certain way
that's a full-time job a lot of times
like the amount of work you have to do
here's my thing if if you have if I have
to weigh my listen to get I was gonna
say everybody weighs left listen to get
the shredville to get a six-pack to look
like those guys and the fitness industry
and you're weighing your food and
Counting every calorie yeah there's
nothing
on this planet that I would that I would
be willing to do that to if they're like
hey if you just stick this for three no
did I hurry that's exhausted did I tell
you that I I meet with this guy a long
time ago and he goes uh he goes uh so
what do you want from your you know we
were talking about exercising I'd like
to put on more muscle because how much
you want to put on I go I thought to be
180 he goes all right you want to be 180
or 185 I go well I don't have that
genetics he goes of course you do I mean
what do you want to be I'd love to be
180 185. you know all [ __ ] you seem so
common too he goes all right and he's he
emailed me a meal plan
and what I have to weigh out and stuff I
just do all that Lance did it and I went
this is nice let's do all that [ __ ] this
has never happened when my freshman in
college I was Underside so I put all
that I do that meal plan drink the
shakes the high calorie shakes [ __ ] I
had it in my dorm room you're farting
all the time oh dude it was so stupid oh
I I know a guy who woke up every four
hours he'd eat every four hours
including at night he'd wake up and eat
and he was like my I just was farting no
no my body was just wait it can't be an
alarm at two in the morning to eat well
your body never like really resets it's
always constantly in the work mode
breaking things down ages oh no yeah
what on the diet did you not like like
you looked at it what stuck out of
something it wasn't that it was just
yeah I just wanted I knew I wasn't
really lead that many times a day and
also I knew I wasn't going to weigh my
food and I also knew I wasn't going to I
just am not that guy you also didn't
want it that bad but you know it's dope
now like there was no reason for me when
I when I was cutting down to two like I
had to get to 218. yeah there's like
meal plans out and I got down to 221 but
there's meal plans now where they
literally I remember they give it all
the exact portions so eat this you're
gonna make this wait I remember that and
even that like after three weeks I was
like you you carry you carry uh 245 very
easily yeah when I was 221 I you know I
was I still was in like shredville I
didn't feel that great you've never
really fluctuated in your weight you're
pretty consistent yeah yeah you know
sometimes I'll see you like you were
lifting heavy for a while oh you've been
and I was like oh you're you're as big
as a human being yeah well then Brian
Shaw says hold myself that's the thing I
always think of you as super strong
which you are
and also he's so much bigger it was like
when I saw you with Justin Tuck and and
uh Alden Smith and you're like oh dude I
mean you know you think Brennan's a big
[ __ ] guy right and then I saw him
standing there at a wedding with Justin
Tuck and Alden Smith they're two
defensive ends yeah
and and I went well my friend is
yeah I went oh Brennan's small and then
of course I got up next week what does
that make me compare me to Brian Shaw
like in the weight room it's like
watching my special like I like Burr's
bed you know
Bill Burr's been up 40 years the best of
the best the number one guy his friends
have been doing seven years so his
strength so he was he was he said let's
see what you can do let's see what you
can pinch and lift I actually cleared
the top rack I was all right I got I
just thought how much weight uh you know
I pinched nothing it was like uh 40
pounds or something or maybe maybe it
was 60 pounds
God I love chalking up no I let nothing
gives me more of a so much fun I'll do
the LeBron oh and then I'll even put it
on my because chicks take that so I'll
put it like all over like I've been
there for hours well with his gym which
is probably a million dollars worth of
equipment I I can see getting into
lifting heavy and feeling stronger like
even for me I was like I could if I was
younger I it would be a it would be a
thing like I love when I'm in that mode
where I'm like all right let's put on
weight get really strong I love it in
the feeling I love it ah let me
completely honest I'm seeing a gym in
two months you haven't no I just I go
through these phases because you know
I've been doing yeah yeah yeah yeah I go
through his face I'm like no I it
literally like the site driving by I'm
like wow it's interesting I get it and I
could watch them right now probably do
225 25 times like it's just natural for
me but I don't drive by I'm like I get
it and it's just like and I used to
force myself then I'd be like miserable
and then I'm like just take a break dude
like you my dad was like hold on it's
not like this is a lifestyle for he's
like it's not like you're never gonna go
back he's maybe just been doing so
you've been running so hard just take a
break from me you've done it so
consistently oh yeah so have you just
not been working out for two months I
don't think no I ride my bike and I'll
go on Hikes but as far as like it's fine
no just took a break sometimes you just
don't want to be you just took your
lifting weights yeah I thought you know
the music the atmosphere I'm not even
hungry I just don't
I also been running hard I did six
weekends in a row yeah you know it's
just like I'm tired and then I want to
spend more time with the kids I'm like
it's a lot I call it hygiene so I do my
20 minutes every other day and it's a
tough 20 minutes that's enough yeah
that's all I that's all I need I'm
saying I drive by and it's like I don't
want to be yeah I I couldn't believe I
dead lifted 300 pounds I want to see you
get up to 400. I I if it was a crossbar
and I worked at it I I think I could do
I know for a fact you could do yeah but
you could do it if you did 300 an
incremental program yes and and B was it
like and they're like come on bro you're
like yeah it wasn't that hard for me to
be honest with you he said they even
said you didn't shake you just like I I
yeah I set my body and I just [ __ ] did
you have to pause did you have to pause
on the quads no oh yeah you could
probably do I mean well I would 400 for
sure if you like committed to it I have
to get you there I don't know if I would
do that that's dangerous that's what I
was gonna say it depends how much you're
willing to sacrifically I don't want to
do anything
right yeah 350 and then he said Brian
said to me he said is if you can do the
weight with perfect form that's how you
stay injury free it's when you your back
arches and you're 55. well that's when
you're mad
your form your form but the same
competition then it's just like by any
means I ain't doing that and then my
back goes say less Daddy no
I I now did you ask Branch all the
hard-hitting questions
um what that dick do well I said if he's
a size I asked 19 of course I asked him
that question of course I asked off
camera on camera on camera I'm watching
now I was gonna pass this one no no
you'll like it and I said I said well
now what that dick you're I said your
head I said I adore I you got an
adorable face I like that your head is
proportioned with your body favorite
part about it you got a button nose you
got a button you got a button nose you
got those big dick beaters
for fingers you got hands you got feet
that's how I know he's a girthy dick
those fingers correct sir and I said now
let me ask you was God did God complete
the job did God go all the way from head
to toe did God take a coffee break when
he's doing the dish or did he take a
coffee break when he was doing the dick
did the god hit the space bar when hit
that dick and and and and
Brian said Brian look at me and goes
everything is proportional
but he he got he got he narrowed his
eyes he got quiet at first he goes yes
to both questions I just got chills I
know I go yeah but that thing is nice
but I love I love the coffee break
metaphor yeah because apparently with
Shaq and shackles took a little coffee
break yeah because not everyone's like
well small dick because he's whatever
seven foot I'm like small small because
I'm thinking checks God might have gave
you everything I'm gonna take a break
here because you know what God does a
lot of times he says you can't have
everything also he meant to go power nap
might have taken a power nap you can't
have everything right I wish Brian Shaw
was like I also chalk up when I jack off
because I you know I get a I need the
grip there you go I need the grip need
the grip
don't do that please
don't do that I mean I bet that thing's
yeah some balls like a [ __ ] great
dane too huh yeah although I would I
wonder if he mad he's not in Game of
Thrones
that guy's so busy with his business
selling supplements and all that stuff
oh my God uh you know what I like about
him too I watched him take his own
supplements watch him take his own [ __ ]
and I thought that was pretty cool
because what happened was he said to me
he goes he had partnered up with people
with for the supplement business and
it's sturdy it's a dirty business oh
yeah you know people fillers he goes the
only way I can do this if I do this
myself and I I just fell in love with
the guy I fell in love with it it sounds
like it I just [ __ ] get off with this
big thick no you'll be on a stick too
and we're gonna get him here I've been
on his dick he's from Colorado I think
he can fit in that chair absolutely not
he so I did this his podcast and his
chair was so big I was like what and he
goes yeah I had him custom made these
are my chairs oh I bet his bed's
custom-made
drives a truck he drives a job 350. he
loves he goes he can't fit in [ __ ]
sports cars and he likes cars because I
can't I can't there's no sports car I
can fit into it because I he goes I I'm
too big to even to be a car guy because
no he but he could uh like with some of
the NBA guys do they have the they're
gonna custom make the seat so they go
all the way back now you look terrible
no that's good that's not his problem
it's not length it's the width he
doesn't have his hips are too wide his
body's too wide bub
yeah you go watch this we can't play any
of this on airbrush no oh really no no
but it's YouTube yeah it doesn't matter
that's his content I didn't know that
yeah he squatted a car
that's his truck yeah of course he has
that truck
what's that thing oh they're saying how
much it weighs oh he's truck shopping
and car squatting
oh that's the control of the thing that
picks up the truck is it a Prius he's so
big no Bubba he's so big look at this
look at that cat look at that phone no
even his face I know the phone looked
like a ticket Tic Tac we were drinking
wine and he and my friend goes to him he
goes look at that wine glass in your
hand now you don't want to say too much
of this because he deals with this all
the time but his wrists are what got me
his wrists are so thick I couldn't
that's my hand Rolex not for him no no
he's not finding anything but also look
at this show Jack
it's a raptor or no no that's a Shelby
uh F250 yeah that's right yeah F-150
Shelby yeah those are sick look at him
next to his truck yeah he's not drunk he
looks like Wreck-It Ralph you're the
strongest man
he's just it's tonight I mean when
you're that big it's just life's
complicated yeah you know Shaq this
funny even track when you're single for
a side piece he was hooking up with so
much she goes I come one day and these
people drop off the spin and start
setting it up and he's like hey if I'm
gonna be over there I have to be able to
fit in the bed and put in like this
custom giant [ __ ] round bed because I
I can't sleep
God I am I can't sleep on the floor if
we're gonna hang out it's not it's just
too big it's not easy and shoes I think
he shot's like size 22 or something or
something yeah disaster like if you're a
sneaker had like the shoe drops yeah
none for you but there's nothing would
you say he's um the most astonishing
athlete given his size and he's [ __ ]
up there when he's young for when he
when he was a like a rookie insane he
could run the court dunk dribble nuts
but you know who's bigger free than him
hold on
hold on LeBron
no I mean LeBron's a [ __ ] free but
he's like six eight um the Greek Feller
the MVP really yeah he was Giannis yeah
he was from Milwaukee yeah you see how
tall is he honest what's this that you
can shoot he can do it all yeah yeah
like Shaq Couldn't Shoot six alone
that's his body bring let me reject
that's his [ __ ] body I think his he
has two brothers too and they're also in
the NBA
uh he's originally from somewhere in
Africa yeah uh yeah he's black Brian no
no no no he's from Greece though he grew
up in Greece but his family my
immigrated from somewhere in Africa yes
100 that's what that's him but look how
big he is but then he's different than
like a David Robinson or like even a
shot because he can dribble finesse the
ball like move he's just a super freak
Shaq was a to your point though Shaq was
a Freakazoid yeah look at his body
look at that
oh my God and and [ __ ] is I mean that's
stupid my stomach doesn't he's the best
basketball player on Earth though yes
yeah yeah look at his look at his arms
now the guy who won MVP and deserved it
for Denver Nuggets Djokovic doesn't look
like that but he's so skilled look at
how look at how weightlifting
that's interesting that's interesting
that's interesting hold on here hold on
hold on it says Giannis put on 51 pounds
of muscle since entering the NBA
everybody calm down how old was he when
he entered this could help us he was
young he was young so you have to give
that up you got a little bit of that up
and he probably never lifted weights
before this 51 pounds of muscle and it's
like was it all muscle yeah he grew he
grew into it he's only 28. so how old
was he when he entered professional
career
but no you said the NBA starting 2013.
yep
yeah okay so if he's 28 now he's 18.
he's been playing since the eighth yeah
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
yeah
that's him in 2014 right here
now when you when a guy like that is a
super athlete lifts weights that much
food you're you're gonna gain yeah he
takes it serious 2016 here
you do run a lot you do run a lot he's
thin so 2016 here yeah uh let's keep
going 2018. okay put a little more a
little bit more size yeah
I mean I just want to pretend he grew
into his man's body you know listen
steroids okay I hate this Brandon
there's an elephant in the room there's
elf in the room Brendan and that
elephant's on Deca right pregnant
there's elf in the room and it's just
because his delts look like cantaloupes
it's not a reason for you to say that
you want to play a fun game daddy or not
bring up David Robinson
now he wasn't Abby sure was he because
they didn't test back then oh is he sir
oh bring up his shoulders for me no his
he was such a freak but he was always a
freak
he was always right there that looks
insane those are rock hard look at that
and you are suggesting that maybe
why wouldn't you is that him there I
mean I think some of this this might be
photoshopped I think yeah this has to be
photoshopped I don't know
I don't know no they were always
the one where he's his arms are down
with the spurs fit the number 50 Jersey
right above you chin right above there
that one yeah good on that that's how he
looked yeah he looked like that when he
got older in his career and he was seven
feet tall
I don't know how tall he was David
Robinson was easily seven feet tall
uh go ahead and take a look at how tall
he was now that's crazy
someone one okay okay
so there's one guy that I believe that
was playing back then was it on steroids
only one guy so so that back then was
the hey Dave John Stockton was on the
liver King stack listen
no I'm just kidding the one guy who was
on wasn't on it guarantee it
Manute Bol and Larry Bird Manute Bol
Larry had some really aggression
problems but Manute Bol I can co-sign I
saw him in person didn't touch a thing
he was from the Sudan I've never seen
anybody asking anymore his son bolbo is
a beast like look at his his arms are
like they're just like piped from a
place I saw his legs and stuff it was so
weird he he knew it was it was tough for
him to walk around like that he died
right
who would you rather be there's a
picture that would rather be Spud Webb
where you're tiny or Manute me too yeah
it died in 2010. oh he's so young he was
seven foot seven so you're you're not
seven seven two hundred pounds yeah and
then his son's a baller too the Nuggets
didn't have him I think they cut him he
might still be on there but you yeah I'd
rather be Spud you're living way longer
oh yeah spuds the [ __ ] yeah you want to
be a great dane you want to be a
Chihuahua Chihuahuas live for [ __ ]
ever
spring Chihuahua yeah that's bull ball
there 17 can hit threes is that right
yeah that's the sun right there looks
just like his dad
damn that's bull ball
that's Sudanese that's not uncommon in
Sudan tallest people in the world they
say that Dutch are but the Dinka and the
new tallest people again gun to the Head
who's non-steroids that guy yeah that
might be a good guy to be on but you got
to be careful with your heart when
you're that tall and there's a lot of
issues oh everything I mean but have you
the kid who's the number one Prospect is
they list them at I think seven two
and he has the handles and the shooting
actually of like Kevin Durant but he's
7-2 and he's from Paris he's gonna be
the number one pick they're saying he's
the best talent we've seen since LeBron
what he's 7-2 can handles shoot these
shots are nuts he scored like 40 points
in the NBA like preseason thing they do
in Vegas how do you guard him
that's him everyone's gunning for him
once in a millennium Prodigy here's the
thing they say 7-4 they have a picture
him next to this guy who plays in the
NBA for the he used to play for the Jazz
from Milwaukee now he's seven like two
he's way taller than him
way taller good God
that's a tall dude look at that he was
seven for eleven three-point shot his
his fingers are they go on for days he's
got those E.T fingers they go on for
days I'm sorry but I have to say no his
fingers go on foreign
yeah he's got
but he's like a Great Dane out there
like he's floppy you know he's so big
and they shouldn't be that you know
coordinated it's nuts dude everyone's on
his nuts yeah his digits go on for days
everyone's on them big long yeah yep yep
um seven four and he's lead us oh he can
move oh yeah seven four dude yeah he can
move but he's also got look at that
is still young right so homeboy is going
to be filling out I think he's like this
teenager so he's he might be 16. oh
that's stupid but look at where he
shoots the problem is India he can do a
fade away so all the NBA stars like
tweeting about him because his first
like it was in the NBA but it was like
the the the thing that they do the camp
that made does and he's going against
another really good guy he's supposed to
draft high he hung like 50 points on the
[ __ ] you can't stop him a fade away
no but he's almost he's 18. he's 18.
he's almost too tall when when I watch
him I go you ain't stopping that fade
away that's what I said come to stand I
do he does look flying he's stopping out
fade away I'll take you from here B
let's take a little break because we
talking about Rogue nicotine we talking
about Rogue timeout Rogue if you're a
regular viewer of any show that I do you
know I love Rogue I use their pouches
every single day on podcast Jim ride my
bike while I'm driving I mean everywhere
my favorite flavor right now is the
Apple I also enjoyed the lemon but they
have Wintergreen they have peppermint
they have Berry they got it all the
flavor of Roy Rogue destroys anything
out there that's why I decided to go
with them you can get pouches in three
or six I use the six and go through a
can a day so that's cool what got you to
start doing it uh I just love the taste
of it man and listen if you want to
switch it up too if you want to switch
it up you don't want to be a pouch
person that's cool they have gum tablets
lozenges they got it all I take it
anywhere I want on flights through the
airport comedy clubs all over Rogue is
my go-to source for nicotine when I'm
riding doing whatever I do I love it I
reached out to him to be part of my show
because I use Rogue more than any other
product in my life it's fantastic if you
want to try the pouches like me or the
gums tablets everyone get your nickname
go to roguenixteen.com use code rogue20
for twimps off your order again that's
Rogue 20 for 20 off your order
they're the best of the best it's the
best nicotine on the planet and we're
talking about Rogue nicotine baby
underage sales prohibited warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical for more information
visit Rogue nicotine.com
on it.com slash f a t k if you want the
best nootropic on the market Alpha Brain
is their top seller unless you're gonna
trust they have Alpha Brain Black which
is the high concentrated Alpha Brain
they got Warrior bars protein powder
krill oil fish oils they got all sorts
of goodies and all things who else are
you going to trust honestly around
forever well they sold over a million
bottles and also they believe so much in
alphabet if you don't like it you get
your money refunded guaranteed no need
to send it back go ahead and keep it but
I guarantee you guys are gonna like it
if you want to save 10 off everything on
it supplements workout Gear streaming
Fitness Alpha Brain go to audit.com
f-a-t-k all right go to audit.com
f-a-t-k you have 10 off the entire thing
you're welcome on it holler so he's
already Pro in France yeah
he coming he coming
yeah he's coming okay isn't that nuts
and it just everybody want them
everybody everybody
look at him there just a young yeah
because when I first heard about I
looked him up and it was him it was like
French high school or something it's
just him and these little small French
guys white guys I was like well yeah
yeah he's seven four yeah playing
against that is weird skinny and Tall
yeah that's weird skinny and Tall that's
alarming yeah you'd have him on a weight
lifting program in a food program oh
we're running a heavy stack gotta run a
heavy stack because that's food jump
through the roof
yeah because I feel like he's strong but
he could be broken
that kid's a baller next to him oh
really yeah Gonzaga
yeah
that's my favorite body part to be
honest with you like oh it's a disaster
yeah you don't look cool in anything no
you only look cool on a basketball court
yeah like outside of that you look
ridiculous yeah I'd way rather like when
they dress up it's like holy [ __ ] I
think I don't know say something that's
a good body but you know I'd like to
look like a professional the guy on the
right looks sick yeah like one of the
things who do you think have okay I'm
Gonna Give You best bodies ready out of
athletes watch so I'm gonna give you
soccer players on average this is
average soccer players
swimmers oh no water polar players
wide receivers in the NFL
middle linebackers
basketball players on average that's
what's the word well you water Poland
swimming take out right well water polo
players have very good bodies but
swimmers don't have ass or legs really
no no they're built like the built like
stingrays good bodies though handsome
tall their legs or nothing yeah I gotta
see I need I need they have no ass
either the wieners I need more in the
ass and more and less personally I need
some more trunks correct you feel me uh
I mean definitely NFL like DNS or like
outside linebackers like uh stupid like
a Nick Bosa stupid boy fine stupid phone
big boasts of fun we went to the game
and my girl goes where's Garoppolo I go
Garoppolo looks like a turd next to look
at how it goes look at how that's she
goes where's Bosa it's not fair to be
that good looking [ __ ] off oh well and
he's up for NFL MVP and he's missed a
ton of game he's such a baller look at
him now he was the first pick in the NFL
I mean brother was the first I would
wear that all the time
I'd wear it all the time
I'd wear that [ __ ] sleeveless
that sleeveless Body Glove tight and
those [ __ ] shorts that's a get out of
here with your arms and tits yeah I
would I would just got tits I'm with you
I'd only wear that or no no T-shirt I'd
be like the liver king of football oh
[ __ ] off I wear half shirts look at his
abs he's such a freak his jawline he's
got hair I'm a piece of [ __ ]
somebody put me out of my misery
look at it it went to the game it was
Niners versus uh Rams my girl's like
where's Grappler I'm like oh you don't
know she's waiting on you yeah you don't
know you've never seen Nick Bosa he
makes Garoppolo look like [ __ ] yeah
she's like once when's naked like the
big boy down there 97. once you get your
peepers on them her mouth was drooling
and so was mine no no both of us well I
I would out of respect you must you must
let your lady
dip her toe in the pool of sin oh like a
dowry or like a signed jersey you've got
to understand that in life there is a
pecking order and you and I are very
aware of that we've done fine but if
your girl wants to dip her toe in the
pool of sin take a little r r from
spending time with you not Garoppolo not
him he's a stud dog he's out for the
season no but Garoppolo listen he would
have been the reason the Niners don't
win the Super Bowl and he broke his foot
but he he dates porn stars so he's cool
but
I'm gonna have to if he's looking at my
girl I go yeah dude go ahead yeah hey
I'd say is that him really yeah I'm
gonna take the wheels a little bit look
at him he kicked the wheels are you
kidding me though go and kick the wheel
yeah kick the wheel kick the wheel kick
the wheels a little bit you want to kick
the wheels because hey
hey bossa if you want to play with the
trunk
if you want to play with the trunk she
opens business listen if you wanna if
you wanna if you wanna go Donuts in the
field I'd say I'm talking about butt sex
he'd go hey you go oh Jesus
my girl that's his girl looks like it
well he he's so lucky he gets older
right
she should be she should wake up every
morning thanking her [ __ ] lucky stars
she should wake up every morning pray
too wait a minute hold on go back to
what she's in a go back to that that's
her
is this one picture of everybody oh my
Lord yeah that's her dude who else no
this picture's like it'll be a snitch
dude if it wasn't don't be a hater yeah
you get well you hate model and Tick
Tock sensation she should be
you get washing his feet dude
she's well they're both impossibly hot
she's so attractive if you were in so
they're naked you would have to know
she's lying she's oh look she's she's
shocked oh she's so hot Jesus but of
course dude I get your dick both you're
the captain of the [ __ ] 49ers you're
gonna win NFL teams play of the year
I've lost all energy in my body I mean I
feel weak me too I don't know who I'm
more attracted to me neither I'm so
confused right now I'm so gay
God damn it but I also I'm also in love
when I came here right now I was like
listen if you kill Brian on how much you
love if you kill Brian you'll spend the
night with you I would choke you up and
you would have tears in your eyes
tears of joy yeah tears of joy and then
after after I bust my nut it'd be so sad
you'd be so sad but during what I'm
thinking about this so sad but but you
know there's only 300 followers
twenty three thousand I'm not sure if
there's the same girl though the same
name but I'm not sure all right
perfect that'll take you over that'll
take you over that'll take you over that
that's spellbinding you murder for her a
murderer Jenna murder For Hire if she
goes can you rob a bank for me I'd go
how about you is it a U.S Bank I gotta
start organizing that U.S banks are
pretty strict but I'll try my best but
if I if I I'd say hey if I go to Slammer
for five to seven years you wait for me
right you didn't pay me conjugal vids
look at that wait go which one I just
keep going I feel sick all right go to
that one right I feel weak that one
brought you under her boob are you
talking about
the red shirt
yeah the Richard well look I mean better
think twice I mean
yeah that's that's I like the quotes too
man make you think if you're both says
that's what that's what happens if
you're Bosa now when when Bosa takes
your shirt off she goes I'm so lucky
every morning she should otherwise he
needs to get someone else yeah yeah
cause I'll do it man yeah yeah
I know she better be watching his
[ __ ] feet what's bus away I got it in
I got an end I'm just like 260.
shredville well then his brother Joey
both says in charges he says yeah Mom
Mom two six whoever
white meat we gotta take moms we gotta
take Mom's womb womb and figure out a
way to put that into
can I see Bose's parents I want to see
who made that hey but you know what's
going on I bet they have like the weird
third brother who didn't get the same
genetics oh boy he spelled like me he's
like their manager so like me walking
around all Angry he's the manager but he
gets a hot chick just from the runoff of
his brothers now the other brother you
know
phenomenal athlete is that that
so Dad playing the NFL too and Uncle oh
okay they're all studs yeah look at the
dad right there yeah
which one all did that one let me see
that one where I want to see Dad with
his arms no the one within the gym chip
yeah in the gym gym third oh man you're
the worst chin huh
there you go there we go that's dad
that's dad well Dad's built like a brick
[ __ ] house we played he was a former NFL
also Dad don't work out with all those
wristbands his dad's gotta yeah he's got
a very big head himself that's a big
head big jaw big job yeah and those he
looks like the French guy from Mike
Dyson's punch out hit it Ted get ready
for this the French guy who holds the
Rose from Mike Tyson's punch out is
their dad on steroids Brennan's always
on top I've never met anybody who's
better at this
yeah no no wait which one do you
remember
yeah no no the original yes right there
oh there you go no it was the other
one's better but that's him that is him
wow this is Brenda's gift it's a weird
gift it's such a goddamosa all the town
in the world and he was like I guess
we're better among the brothers
right right now is Nick because he's
playing I think Joey's out for the
season but they're both ridiculous but
Nick Bosa is I mean that's huge too or
that is that Nick Buffalo yeah snake on
the far right those are the boys yeah
where it is to have two brothers play in
the NFL you know rares and Dad but it's
all genetic isn't it there's the dad and
for the Dolphins that's the mother and
uncle look at the mom their house is it
now is it just the two of them to have a
younger one who's you know kind of like
the smart like you know I don't know Mom
Mom is no slow slouch either oh Mom's a
big strong name 100 yeah Mama's womb
needs to be plated in gold
that's impressive
if you type in Nick Bose uh Brothers is
it just those two I think so mom's got
big bones you see mom's bones
yes mom's got broad shoulders that's a
good call a little bit Yeah there's only
two of them so it's not a third one who
hates his life so you got boys you got
boys with some speed you got you got
some speed on them dude if those were my
sons if that was Tiger in Boston out of
a San Diego Chargers tattoo or La
Chargers tattoo on the side of my neck
here yeah a Niners tattoo on the side
here yeah and I just and they would say
Yep they're mine yeah yeah I would have
you know what tattoo I'd have and I'd
say son don't bring your girlfriend
don't bring your girl around holidays
you know what my tattoo would be if I
was one of them my tattoo would be
she's so lucky she's so lucky oh if
you're Nick Bosa she's so lucky
why possibly lucky you're lucky you're
lucky that's something you're unlucky
the Bosa Bros
one of them took some time to grow
but you can already see he's a thick
[ __ ] big heads
and also they were they were schooled in
the game of football by dad right yeah
their dad played it was number 90. dad's
got a hell of a head of hair
is he an Italian Stallion bosa's Italian
That's Italian what else are they I'm
gonna make a call right now I'm gonna
make a call they got out of some Dutch
or they got another slave they're Slavic
mom somebody's somebody's Slavic let me
see they're not pure Italian are they
oh I guess if the dad played for Miami
and they grew up in Florida yeah they
might be some Cuban in there no no no no
no don't put stuff it's probably because
they're they're white no dad the other
white and they don't steal this from us
Brian let's try you woke [ __ ] but um
they're white right Dad was a first
round uh draft pick and so was their
Uncle okay
Chicago outfit Tony Accardo they're all
Bubba they stayed disciplined and let me
tell you why they stayed disciplined
because I'm going to tell you what's up
no because the men said
I might be attracted to small women I
might be attracted to that skinny dancer
over there I'm marrying a farm girl I'm
gonna marry my equivalent as a woman I
need a big bone strong athletic woman
and that's when you get freaks
yes I do mom's gotta be mom's got to be
you know it takes two to tango you you
can't just
I mean the Gene's coming to the dad but
yeah I hear you yeah you know
but look at your like Joe's athletic Joe
comes like Joe's strong muscular herbs
her brothers yeah so your boys have good
there's some good thank God my boy's got
her calves
she has big cast yeah big calves yep
yeah I don't come from my family tree
not not good your dad [ __ ] up because
you're because Mike Big Mike is Big we
call him Big Mike big but Mama too tiny
and tiny tiny Italian lady and that
muscular your dad wasn't thinking Sports
most don't why would you no you find the
love of your life you're like you're
just not big enough that's it she was
like but we connect he's like I'm sorry
tiny bit curvy as I'll get out my mom
when she was younger my mom had a blow
up impossible your mom had a blowout ass
the biggest like an hourglass figure so
oh Beyond oh impossible ass and also the
biggest breasts you've ever seen no the
big tits the biggest is your mom Nancy
Pelosi I'm talking about your mom Polo
see 100 your mom has sweater hitters
with all due respect my mom my mom
whenever I'm around your mom let him out
she said 82 now please please let them
out
every now and then Bubba
she's 82. now when she was younger it
was impossible
she had a shelf hey let me see your
mouth hey hey
shelf your mom stacked huh like as in
like Bobo boom Sophia Loren body crazy
ass and I mean letter s built like the
letter s well that's why your dad did it
that's right situation big money no
situation now he's built like
Frankenstein yes he's built like Franks
I said to my brother my his brother his
brother was an All-American pitcher his
brother was very athletic a very good
pitcher and I said my dad he goes your
dad was was slow
very slow strong not a fast guy strong
like a like a like a uh a Workhorse you
know you attach him to an ox you attach
him to like you wanna you wanna you
wanna plow a field or a grind grain yeah
your dad's an ox and I listening to me
and your mom was there
a
cheetah
I don't like
keep your hips
keep your hips still
when my mom when when you mentioned my
when my mom's name is in your mouth keep
your hips still bro that's the second
time it's happened on the show Nick
Bose's girlfriend and your mom
foreign
God damn it I want to stab
I didn't know your mom had them sweater
hitters back I'm gonna stack your mom
don't say that because me your mom and
Aunt nubby have a thing I know and now
I'm giving it right be cool everybody
should be cool you'd be cool man your
mom though your mom ties traded me in
for Mark
yeah she won Mark unbelievable she used
to crush on you oh it's my girl that's
my lady hey man hey my girl you've hung
out with her we've hung out when she
came to the show there's a connection
for sure hey I'm talking hey don't back
me I'm talking to me don't back me in
corner talking [ __ ] about my own make me
well your mom right because now I know
these facts which you didn't tell me
your mom's a stone cold cheetah all
right
sir cheetah sir she's 82. please be
respectful I'm an old cheetah please be
respectful I'm cheetah but mom mama mama
shop she's got a thing for for big Mark
but what I'm saying is she thinks from
Instagram but you guys she's not a
master in person for sure you never met
her oh okay yeah okay so she's still my
girl yeah yeah when she hey
[Applause]
said on this podcast he goes and to
where he was like talking about the
people because the people that said that
I was a little too much on that he goes
um
I want your mom to suck my [ __ ] behind
he goes suck my [ __ ] from behind so that
her nose is in my [ __ ] oh she's
sucking because I thought he was going
to do an apology because I just want to
say to everybody I offended I I have
your mom suck my [ __ ] from behind her
nose is in my [ __ ] I love it I was
like holy [ __ ] that's aggressive and
hilarious that's so oh it's so funny
suck my dick for one sucks that nose in
my head let me hide so that your nose is
in my [ __ ] all right we covered a lot
of ground today yeah chin what do you
got all right first of all Tyler shows
me Brian's mom's a cheetah
okay first of all sad news uh Mills Lane
you guys know I met him I worked with
him referee Mills my TV show he's
actually he had a really amazing history
too he was a
lawyer than a judge right so apparently
20 years was it 20 years ago did he have
his own show too
I did it yeah wow he died but he was
like one of the best boxing referees out
there like really on point yeah Tyson
Holyfield fight 20 years ago he lost the
abilities yeah so he couldn't he
couldn't referee again but then he
suddenly yeah how old was he he was in
his 80s I think yeah
good run yeah that stroke shit's no joke
though that sucks yeah hey have you seen
uh
you ever looked up how much Judge Judy's
worth yeah hundreds of millions of
dollars just from that TV show yeah
this stuff is so weird it's syndicated
all over the world
when that happens so when you own a
piece of that foreign
that show is so stupid yeah
and she'll be like what were you
thinking you guys like I don't know dude
so we've all lived here in LA and this
is happening more and more often uh it's
called Bank jugging so if you ever go to
an ATM or go to the bank to pull out
cash
people are getting robbed more than ever
now and they're waiting for you to go to
the ATM and they're like or even even
the bank so if you go to the bank more
they'll see you coming out of the out of
the bank and they'll rob you well they
assume I have cash of course yeah
you shot uh Lady Gaga's dog walker you
got 21 years yeah for shooting a dog hey
dum dum you try to steal a dog and then
shot the guy in the chest yeah 20 years
old oh you shot the end of the chest I
thought you just cut the top yeah what
are you in for I was trying to steal a
dog and I shot somebody over a dog a
French Bulldog I shot him in the chest
man oh well he survived he survived he
was like your assistance right yeah he
was like a gay guy remember he was like
yeah he was crying and screaming but he
was fighting him
props that guy yeah I wonder what his
well he when you get shot in the chest I
wonder what his situation is going how
he's doing he must be so in court he
forgave him he goes I forgive you
because I got to move on with my life
which is huge
but I like this [ __ ] whoever he
is shut up I give him so many props
so he got 21 years to for attempted
murder yeah
yeah you shot him in the chest you know
what a piece of [ __ ] and then I mean
even if you get that this is how stupid
you get that French Bulldog
maybe with two girls this is just this
is not somebody who thinks ahead of time
I mean they total of four people
arrested
they find you
put yeah put that up on the black market
just put Lady Gaga's dog walker
okay
maybe he doesn't want to be seen you
know maybe
it's gonna be hit the shooter oh he
doesn't want to be out there maybe it's
just picture of Lady Gaga
wow yeah what a badass yeah he loved
those dogs I'd give that dog up so hope
he's all right man [ __ ] shot in the
chest oh I know
there's all the pups a lot of work
ah man you never thinking it well that
that new bridge they built kind of close
to downtown someone was walking a
Frenchie there and the car just pulled
up two dudes pulled out their guns and
took the dog yeah
yeah because the bridge had a lot of
issues
oh there he is in the hospital bed yeah
man
I'm looking oh they show them like in
the Trap there
oh wow okay
thank God in the Trap let me see this
one could have bled out
God you wish you'd have some that loyal
to
Ryan Fisher
shout out to Ryan Fisher that's pretty
badass gutsy [ __ ] dude man
hopefully hopefully she gives him a
raise
yeah it's still about the shooter yeah
let's move on all right he got shot in
the Trap though you know
you got a lot of veins there though yeah
um so
is like it's pretty much Bridging the
Gap between doing this it's a computer
but attached to your brain so you can
just boom you have all information right
away it's it's linked to our brain like
a chip that goes the guy who's warned
one of the guys who's been very worried
about computers becoming smarter than
people and what it leads to but he's
developing this system yeah I know this
is not this just having the the database
in your so it's available faster so it's
a faster yeah but how stupid like than
like facts and all that [ __ ] and like
Bro Science definitely killed so we
don't have careers but like the the
arguments when you just have all the
information that that right here in the
little device through your brain that
sucked I think so because you're Google
but it doesn't mean you become creative
it just means you have no there's no
creative it's just like
yeah okay so you know how like when we
we all all of us all of us were alive
when the internet started right right so
we saw how bad it was in the beginning
and how much better it is now I think
this could be like bad in the beginning
but then later on
after Elon Musk for no reason we need a
boogie man they've decided he's the bad
guy yeah so this article that's how the
mainstream media is just [ __ ]
unbelievable this way they won't pick up
well because what's it takes attention
away from uh Hunter Biden stuff and the
suppress them off Twitter nobody picks
up that story and they just have to have
a bad guy the guy who creates more jobs
into you people pays more in taxes and
makes American cars you [ __ ] zeros so
yeah so the reason why this article came
out is because it's it's over a backlash
over animal tests but the reality is in
our society we use animals to test a lot
of stuff for medical research yeah and I
and I think I I would like to see what
those animal tests are I just don't buy
it he's just the bad guy well here's
what the net here's what I saw in this
article that Jim I think is pretty lit
though
yeah and all in all the company has
killed about 1500 animals you gotta
crack a few eggs make an omelet include
more than 280 sheep pigs and monkeys
the monkeys and stuff falling experience
since 2019 according to uh reviewed by
Rutgers and source with direct knowledge
all right
I don't know so wait hold on it says
this is a rough estimate because the
company does not keep precise records
than so they're guessing they they and
also medical research we need to test
with we would you rather them test on
human beings or animals but they have to
that would be a cool death sentence
though for like some of these horrible
criminals like hey so we're just gonna
use it for testing yeah that's your
penalty they have definitely uh figured
out a way to try to make him the bad guy
and I just did so that's right yeah yeah
um all right so hold on Trump has lost
his potency now that Herschel Walker
lost that's another guy that Trump
endorsed so his political endorsement is
actually the kiss of death look at it
that's why dissance wants as far as
possible because Trump's not the
political force he was amazing dude do
you see herschel's the guy hers was
going against he gets on he goes do you
really want Herschel Walker for the next
six years no he's like what are we
talking about he's like what are we
talking about stupid candidate man what
do you guys got all right Mark kisses
all right
um I thought this one was interesting I
always find it fascinating when people
lie about having cancer major things and
get called out but great a gray Gray's
Anatomy writer reveals she lied about
having cancer and dead brother
uh Elizabeth Fitch Finch screenwriter
from ABC's drama Gray's Anatomy finally
fessed up to her elaborate medical ruse
I've never had any form of cancer she
admitted to the ankler in a bombshell
interview I told a lie when I was 34
years old and it was the biggest mistake
of my life it just got bigger and bigger
and got buried deeper and deeper inside
me I guess the reason for her lying
about it in the first place was she
really missed having intensive care like
she had an injury people were taking
care of her and Hands-On all the time
and then when that all went away she was
like this sucks
illness yes
um I mean and she based several
storylines for Gray's Anatomy on her
medical history her real medical history
so they thought but and then she also
kind of blames her brother too she was
like terrorizing you know what older
brothers do but he never left a mark I
mean there's could be some mental abuse
he's also older brother I bet the
brothers like don't drag me into this
right yeah it was I mean it's also in
Shameless back and also him you know
Finch left
um so it must be her in the scrubs maybe
yes
she was a writer and she came I don't
trust her just look at it don't trust
her so she was writing about cancer on
her own yeah she chose the specific type
of cancer uh chondro sarcoma due to its
difficulty to treat she told angler as
at the time she spun her first FIB she
also claimed that she lost a kidney and
part of her leg hence the knee
replacement
oh she really get went down a rabbit
hole with this yeah
have you ever have you guys ever known
anybody's life yes I have to cut my leg
off
uh no
no
I had a coach in high school lied about
having cancer it was very confusing
trying to rally the troops though did
you guys win games because he's like if
we don't win four more games super
motivational from a training standpoint
yeah but he was also like he's like if I
can do that you know if I can do it you
guys can do it you know yeah right no we
would look at him he'd come in some days
and he'd just be like
you do all these dramatic like you're
like I just today's rough like I just
came from chemo and he just ran out of
coaching ideas Jesus but he wasn't like
the head coach it was like he came on he
like weaseld his way onto the team and
uh but motive like as far as leading the
kids and making them work hard
couldn't have been done better but if I
was a parent I'd be like it works it
also tracks with some other stuff like
was he [ __ ] a 17 year old female
wrestler yes you know yeah
um and that's what led to his you know
did he even play football right probably
not he would make [ __ ] up like you know
I'm feeling about cancer yeah he's just
that Rock Bottom he has like oh and
three he's about to lose his job he's
like all right I gotta motivate these
little pricks but what you see is people
like so-so pass use lies like that
because sympathy is so powerful to get
people would do to do what you want to
do
Alabama family had a massive
cockfighting ring yeah
yeah one of the largest cockfighting
Enterprises in the US
the seventh and final member of an
Alabama family that prosecutors
allegedly in an expansive [ __ ] fighting
operation complete with stadiums seating
for approximately 150 people holy [ __ ]
and a merchandise stand holy [ __ ] some
merch out the back get your [ __ ] merch
dude what a hustle what a hustle is
right yeah 22 months in prison uh George
easterling was 56. uh 22 months followed
by one year supervised release after
pleading guilty would you want to sell
merch though if you're doing an
underground top fighting thing yeah like
you gotta hope nobody posts like where'd
you get that Alabama cockfighting
Championship 2018 shirt what I made it
yeah uh they put they put razor blades
on some crazy cockfighting yeah
uh 1500 bucks a fight participants will
charge expensive fees to enter the birds
oh yeah
1500 to fight seven roosters
1300 bucks you get seven ghosts serious
[ __ ] dude and told weapons to strap to
the rooster's legs such as short knives
damn those night those roosters had
Shanks on them wow now
was it entertaining
well you're a [ __ ] with a shank yeah Roy
Jones Jr he uh his dad used to breed I
think dogs and [ __ ] that's right the
roostering chase
would you want to watch the birds
actually kill each other though would
that be satisfying too no that'd be
stupid
but also I don't like birds I think
they're creepy people chickens though so
I hate birds they're so creepy uh yeah I
do Yeshua chicken you know Duck's nice
even though I like ducks
I mean everybody's doing a show in
Alabama so I was like hey dude there's
this you ever seen Lionheart and Van
Damme like yep all right that they're in
wife beaters but they're roosters with
knives I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah I want in
right sure
you have something to do once
I I guess you probably you feel pretty
[ __ ] [ __ ] dirty I mean people are
taking pictures it's a long history of
it there's a lot like just the way you
breed like the way they would breed pit
bulls to fight yeah that that [ __ ] is
like that that's old school science I
mean they would do dogs I couldn't watch
dogs these dogs will fight for an hour
and a half oh they fight to the death
dogs I absolutely cannot watch it's
crazy roosters yeah and those dogs live
their life at the end of a chain and
then they usually just put them right
they lose yeah but I couldn't do that
yeah it's like a racehorse or something
yeah I've left and all it's God's
creatures right yeah it really just down
but it's still a rooster it's still a
bird so if I had to watch that to choose
yeah rooster first dog no rooster I can
stomach a rooster because I eat chicken
I don't watch bunnies with [ __ ]
knives on their back leg a couple couple
hairs desert hairs coming out yeah dude
you want them big bunnies well there's
that they're super heavy now a desert
hair when a hawk comes down they've been
known to jump in the air and just kick
that they'll kick a snake out the out
the way they'll kick a [ __ ] uh yeah I
like it doesn't Hawk out of the way
you're talking about a sand bunny uh-huh
uh yeah or desert hairs jackrabbits yeah
man desert hairs they're like long and
skinny they can run and they can kick
yeah there is [ __ ] another one up
[ __ ] around everything wants to eat a
bunny though everything their ears are
so long yep Earth thing one they're
death from the sky death from the sky
all the time that my [ __ ] hips right
now look at his ears I think yes he can
hear him he got holy [ __ ] figures holy
[ __ ] big [ __ ] ears yeah they're sweet
though man yeah I'd watch that thing
fight another one you can hear the
flappings of wings above them put some
[ __ ] just two knives on the mirrors
you got Bobcats to worry about you got
snakes to worry about your rabbit you
got coyote story about and keep going
Birds lizards Hawks and Eagles to worry
about people you got people other
rabbits yeah you got it it all sucks
if if we get reincarnated rabbit tough
gig you look stupid you have that tiny
tail you're [ __ ] everywhere but and
you can't even walk you have to jump
everywhere we have to hop everywhere
pigeons or doves and people think oh no
no you can fly you think you have
freedom
owls get you at night when you're in
your nest you're just kind of hanging
out and all of a sudden we gotta be in
the big city though so you gotta be a
city bird you gotta be a city bird
because otherwise them rather Falcons
yeah and Falcons and those birds of prey
get you now if you're a pigeon in the
middle when you're flying in midair they
dive bomb you if that dumbass get your
ass to Chicago
well even then peregrine falcons are all
over New York all over Chicago not
downtown 24 7. not downtown 24 7 costume
pigeon hang out today
[Music]
peregrine falcon don't worry about that
let's see yeah they look like let's see
what they look like [ __ ] yeah all right
Marcus they look like dirty pigeons
which ones you guys want to see cartel
Hitman disappears from U.S prison
interesting
oh
yeah
this guy
cartel Hitman who decapitated enemies
has got a missing from a U.S prison
um a cartel leader in Hitman he
videotaped torture sessions nice guy yep
um he was serving a 49-year sentence in
a federal prison in Florida and
seemingly has gone missing as of
November uh the cartel leader has had
been mysteriously removed from the
Federal Bureau of prison's website he's
now listed as not in BCP custody even
though his release date is not until
July 27 2056. he's known as La Barbie
because of his blue eyes apparently it
is blonde hair that's him that's a
Mexican Feller yeah
um
one point it was the top Lieutenant for
the Sinaloa cartel wow drug dealer
uh El Chapo
and he's just missing yeah so I'm not
too sure if they have any insights on
how he got out or whatever but you know
it's just something that sort of like
quiet like always none of the website
anymore that's strange and then they go
into uh you know like Brendan sort of he
was the only American citizen that ever
wasn't so high on the ranks of Mexico
he's an American citizen yeah he was
born in Laredo Texas bad guy now imagine
you see that guy on the street he kind
of just looks like a regular dude I
don't know if he's got pictures of him
no he is stupid you know
you could push him at a sports bar
watching a game
God who hurt you well that's a guy who
gets off on it he's a real heads killing
people yeah that's a serial killer yeah
that's basically what he is yeah just
got in the dream he gets off to do it
yeah he likes it would have done it even
for yourself yeah what else you got Jim
give us one more
what do you guys want uh what do I have
to choose from here we go uh nope
uh no nudists who only eat fruits camel
beauty contest I knew that she only eats
fruits
all camels look the same all camels
matter wait the nudists are the camels
nudists are all camels so uh these two
influence are fruitarians so they pretty
much only eat fruits maybe a little
vegetables but you know I've met
hardcore fruitarians before we do claim
to like they only eat fruit I think if
you don't supplement a little bit you
can die but uh yeah uh she clearly eats
fruit and doesn't brush her teeth yeah
oh yeah it totally like just fruit
eaters I'm like oh my God yeah I mean
good luck and see how long that lasts
they claim that it's basically cured
their vision problems yeah why does he
have glasses like vision glasses maybe
that was before they cured my eyesight
really nobody died
they came down have no body odor and no
longer have cavities in their teeth I'm
sure nobody she has cavities yeah those
long yellow teeth look at him listen you
probably don't have any body odor
because they're not sweating because
they're gonna die any day
he looks like Brian Shaw looks strong
fruitarianism Kenny bench over 50 pounds
he did lose 33 pounds
dude he said without any effort well
he's got tits all that watermelon game
pepperoni tits wow look at that you
should have seen him before the day yeah
man how do I get a body like that that
looks great yeah who's gonna look at
that either of them be like yeah here's
another Shocker the Israel Israeli
naturalists vowed to not use anything
else non-natural including soap uh they
embrace the nudist lifestyle when they
can eat only fruit leaves and nuts so
they pick themselves how's their
Investment Portfolio
look at how uh yeah he looks uh you know
what this is this is two bored people
with not a lot of money and they're like
hey let's just try and get famous and
eat fruit yeah just like to reinvent the
wheel and just eat fruit they only drink
water from clean streams and fountains
great which are considered to be that's
a young person's face in one year
they'll be eating all the meat and it's
yeah I'll be having [ __ ] a wait a
easy one Burger this bum bum 2022. damn
that's crazy we couldn't possibly click
on that could we oh uses sex as exercise
do you know oh here's a here's a uh
here's a um trivia question what where
is the trans capital of the world Brazil
no Transylvania no oh no I know this
it's uh
this was not a knock knock uh dad joke
right no this is a no because I read
this the other day somewhere strange
yeah look at that who is that she says
five hours of sex a day she does you
have to transfer her ass so transcapital
world uh Brazil no no I said Brazil okay
uh it's somewhere weird like somewhere
over there in uh
oh God you're up no no isn't it but like
Europe Russia ish you could check his
status
good guessing though good guessing
checking status turkey Sweden it's not
turkey sweet it's in Iran it's Tehran oh
that's right because it's illegal to be
gay well because you can't be gay so a
lot of men are like all right hold on
it's gonna be gay but oh my God you
can't be gay so it's like I'm gonna be a
woman then and then then they're like
that's fine yeah now she's um you miss
bum bum 2022. she's got a body on her
now what does she do she just has a lot
of sex you have to get that bum now do
the bums have to be all natural I assume
right
if it's in Brazil I doubt it oh dude
that looks natural to me that looks like
a real ass yeah there's some real ones
out there that one's that's a woman
fantastic yeah yeah she's cool do you
guys know this about Brazil that they do
like uh
publicly funded plastic surgery
yeah
she's pretty fantastic yeah she's cool
yeah very cool you know things are I
don't know
what
an award yeah a strong face
that's the thing she does have like a
masculine on the face yeah yes you guys
are peace
that's different totally different yeah
that's her face yeah well it looks so
different there you know who's done well
there's a lot of makeup going on there
guys
you guys sound like the YouTube counts I
wouldn't do it elbows are pointy
elbows sometimes people have big big
bones in their head yeah you know what I
mean like Mark you're a good looking guy
but I don't want your head on a woman
yeah you're right no you wouldn't yeah
I have the smallest head in here for a
girl you have a big head actually Bob no
I have a big face small head ah get the
measuring tape big face small head you
guys all have small faces small heads
compared to the Future yeah yeah I'm the
biggest one for sure
I mean I'm using yours as a nut ball at
a party you know it's like it was like a
Jeffrey Dahmer party we're using chins
to put the coca-colas in yeah
a couple fresh ones in there single
right there oh yeah Chin's heads for the
Brews
make some pancakes I can't believe you
guys went bad I missed bum bum 2022. oh
that was it then right but she just
looks like she maybe take steroids
yeah she's hot though God bless us God
bless yes that's right well shout out to
Brian's mom my cheetah hey little
cheetah there it is there's my mom
had some work done and there she is her
mom at 87 years old yep
crushing it well kids come see me uh New
Year's Eve laugh Boston December 29 30
31 I'm doing stand-up lap Boston San
Diego comedy mic drop Comedy Club the
next weekend weekend after New Year's I
wonder January five six and seven that's
asking a lot of the people the worst
times a lot of the people that time in
like right around July 4th a little bit
right you always take that weekend off
but yeah I I I wonder I'm gonna call and
I'll tell you I'll tell you yeah I mean
I'm gonna ask I'm gonna call myself no
matter who you are yeah that's a tough
one yeah yeah but you know Fort Wayne
Indiana Club January 13 14 15. no 13-14
sorry uh Dania Florida Dania improv
January 19 20 21 Nashville Tennessee
Xannies March 2 3 and 4. come get some
Sony Hall New York New York March 11th
everybody
all right kids uh I'm taking a break
from stand up I'm off for 2022. uh
picked back up in January of a special
announcement for you guys but this
Friday Barstool Sports rough and rowdy
19 in Providence Rhode Island by the
pay-per-view watch the Cowboys fight
companion
uh live on thick boy YouTube at 5 p.m
Pacific and we got a shake up in the
lineup I think you guys are gonna dig it
we had some big boy hitters For That
season beatings rough and rowdy 19 5 p.m
Pacific this Friday live Cowboys fight
Japan associated with bar stool Sports
is going down 5 p.m tune in live we have
some big boys joining that Saturday 7
P.M Pacific Time live on thick boy
YouTube another fight campaign in
calabas fight campaign we have Brian
Cowan Sam Tripoli Frank Grillo and my
thick self that goes down live this
Saturday 7 P.M Pacific Time thick boy
YouTube but Friday 5 p.m bar stool thick
boy get you some that's it kids love you
you attack some goodbye Brian goodbye
kids